-Friday.
-Today's Friday,
and that's usually when I catch
up with some personal stuff.
I check my inbox.
I return some emails.
And, of course,
send out thank-you notes.
And I was just running...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...running a bit behind.
So, I thought if you guys
wouldn't mind, can I write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now for you guys?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Paul -- Paul, could I get some
"thank-you note writing" music?
-Yes, here it is, yeah.
[ Somber music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-So somber.
-It's so fun.
-This is so fun --
just seeing this
and hearing this.
I'm having the greatest time
right now.
[ Breathes sharply ]
♪♪
Thank you, Beyoncé Tour,
for making my newest hobby
refreshing Ticketmaster.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, cocktail sauce,
for being an overly elegant name
for something that's 90% Heinz.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like, "Cocktail sauce?"
-Ooh-la-la!
-[ Chuckles ]
-Mmm! Catsup.
♪♪
Thank you, massive Chinese
spy balloon over Montana.
I can't wait to see you
in this year's
Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade.
That's going to be --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hey!
Whoa!
[ Chuckles ]
-Coming down 5th Ave.
♪♪
Thank you, snow mobiles,
for looking like
a Transformer planking.
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Netflix
cracking down on shared logins,
for severing our last tie
to our college roommate.
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's it.
Now we're done.
Goodbye.
Out of my life.
-Yeah.
Never going to see them again.
-Out of my life.
♪♪
Thank you, puffy coats,
for giving me full-body abs.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I've got a 20-pack.
♪♪
-I got a washing machine.
-I got a 25-pack.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, Paul Shaffer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
When people -- When people talk
about legends on late-night TV,
you're number one
on everyone's Top Ten List.
There you have it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Those were our thank-you notes.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody!
Come on back!
[ Cheers and applause ]